I'M HERE WITH MY PANEL, "NIGHTLY
SHOW" CONTRIBUTOR, RICKY VELEZ.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
AND THE VERY FUNNY LADIES ON
"BROAD CITY," ABBI JACOBSON AND
ILANA GLAZER.
VERY FUNNY.
BEFORE WE START, I GOTTA SAY IT
DOESN'T FEEL QUITE RIGHT TO BE
AT A DESK WITH THE STARS OF
"BROAD CITY."
YOU GUYS ARE SO CHILL AND RELAX.
IT SEEMS A BIT FORMAL.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A GREAT TIME TO
FINALLY USE THE "NIGHTLY SHOW"
LOUNGE IN COOL MILLENNIAL
HANGOUT AREA HOSTED BY LARRY
WILMORE.
IT'S FOR COOL PEERS LIKE THIS.
SHALL WE?
>> YES.
>> Larry: YEAH!
( APPLAUSE )
ALL RIGHT!
COME ON OVER, LADIES.
♪ ♪ ♪
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> OH, YEAH.
>> Larry: THIS IS BETTER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
( APPLAUSE )
THIS IS A LOT FOR THE.
>> Larry: FEELS BETTER,
DOESN'T IT?
>> YES.
>> Larry: IT SMELLS LIKE AXE
BODY SPRAY AND RED BULL OVER
HERE.
WHAT'S UP, TIM?
HE'S ASLEEP UPON.
DONT WORRY ABOUT HIM.
>> I FEEL LIKE I GOT BED BUGS.
>> LOOK AT THIS, A DOUBLE?
>> Larry: I KNOW, COOL.
>> A DOUBLE BAG OVER THERE.
>> Larry: LET'S GET TO OUR
FIRST TOPIC,  SHALL WE?
SO WE MENTIONED THIS BREAST
FEEDING THING.
THERE IS A THING-- A CONTROVERSY
ABOUT BREAST FEEDING.
I THINK KATHIE LEE AND HODA WERE
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU WATCH KATHIE LEE AND HODA.
>> THOSE ARE MY PEOPLE.
>> Larry: AND THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT WOMEN WHO ARE
OVERSHARING BREASTFEEDING
PHOTOS ON INSTAGRAM.
>> THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF
PEOPLE, HODA-- THOSE WHO FEEL
THE NEED TO SHARE THEIR MOST
PRECIOUS MOMENTS AND THOSE WHO
LIKE TO KEEP THEM PRIVATE, WHICH
I PREFER.
GOD BLESS US ALL.
>> I SAY BREAST FEEDING IS
BEAUTIFUL AND NATURAL, BUT
SHARING IT ON SOCIAL MEDIA?
T.M.I.
>> Larry: THAT WAS JUST
BIZARRE.
>> KNOW.
YOU'RE SCARED TO SAY IT SO YOUR
EMOJIS ARE SAYING IT?
>> Larry: YEAH, WHAT WAS UP
WITH THAT?
BREAST FEEDING ISN'T AWKWARD
ENOUGH.
NOW WE'LL HAVE CARTOON
CHARACTERS TALK ABOUT IT.
DO YOU GUY-- ANYBODY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH WOMEN BREAST
FEEDING IN PUBLIC?
HOW ABOUT THAT FIRST?
>> NOPE.
>> I LOVE IT.
>> I'VE NEVER BEEN MAD AT A
TITTY, LARRY.
LARRY.
I CAN'T REMEMBER BEING ANGRY AT
A TITTY.
>> I HAVE.
>> Larry: YOU DON'T CARE.
>> YOU'VE BEEN MAD AT A TITTY?
>> TWO IN PARTICULAR.
>> Larry: ONE OF THE ISSUES IS
PEOPLE AREN'T JUST DOING IT IN
PUBLIC, WHICH IS FINE.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
BUT THEN THEY'RE SHARING IT ON
INSTAGRAM, WHICH SEEMS A LITTLE
OVER THE TOP.
YEAH, NOW MY TITTIES ARE GOING
TO BE OUT FEEDING A BABY ON
INSTAGRAM.
>> IT'S LIKE--
>> IT'S GETTING IN THE WAY OF,
LIKE, WHAT, TWERKING VIDEOS?
>> I KNOW, WHO CARES.
>> Larry: NOBODY CARES?
>> I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
CAPTIONING.
>> THAT'S LIKE-- PEOPLE TAKE
PICTURES OF THEIR FOOD, AND IT'S
A BABY HAVING ITS MEAL.
>> Larry: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
( APPLAUSE ).
>> IT'S ORIGINAL FOOD PORN.
THERE WE GO.
ORIGINAL FOOD PORN.
>> Larry: DOES ANYBODY THINK
IT'S NARCISSISTIC?
>> I THINK THE INTERNET IS
NARCISSISTIC.
I'M SURPRISED THAT ANYBODY IS
SURPRISED.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IT'S ALL PORN.
INSTAGRAM IS PORN.
TELL THEM TO STOP FOLLOWING
THEM.
>> Larry: NO.
OKAY, SO WE ALL THINK IT'S
COOL?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I'M COOL WITH IT.
( APPLAUSE )
>> THUMBS UP.
THUMBS UP.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT ONE.
EVERYBODY IS WITH BREAST FEEDING
ON INSTAGRAM.
COOL.
WE JUST HAD THE NATIONAL
SPELLING BEE-- I'M JUST A LITTLE
HUNGRY.
THIS IS KIND OF COOL, YOU GUYS.
BEFORE TONIGHT INDIAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS HAVE WON FOR THE LAST
SEVEN YEARS IN A ROW.
THEY'RE CRUSHING IT.
>> YEAH.
>> Larry: AND SOME PEOPLE HAVE
MADE THESE RACIST COMMENTS ON
FACEBOOK SAYING THE KIDS IN THE
SPELLING BEE SHOULD ONLY BE
AMERICAN.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THEY ARE
>> Larry: YES!
WHEN DID WE BECOME RACIST ABOUT
SPELLING BEES?
>> THIS YEAR, I GUESS.
( LAUGHTER )
>> DO THEY ONLY SPELL AMERICAN
WORDS?
>> YEAH, THEY'RE AMERICAN KIDS.
THEY'RE AMERICAN KIDS IN TEXAS.
>> Larry: WHY WOULD PEOPLE BE
UPSET ABOUT THAT?
I DON'T GET IT.
THE OTHER THING IS-- LET ME ASK
YOU THIS-- IS IT OKAY TO FEEL
THAT CERTAIN GROUPS CAN DO
THINGS GOOD?
>> 100%!
IT'S INSANE.
>> Larry: IS IT RACIST TO SAY
A GROUP CAN DO SOMETHING GOOD?
BUT, RICKY, WOULD IT BE WRONG TO
SAY, INDIANS, THOSE ( BLEEP )
CAN SPELL.
>> NO!
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: YOU DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT?
THAT'S TRUE?
>> WHEN YOU'RE LIKE-- I NEED
SOMEBODY TO HELP ME SPELL.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
>> Larry: WHO YOU GONNA CALL?
YOU'RE GOING TO CALL THE INDIAN
GHOSTBUSTERS.
>> WHO DO YOU NEED FOR SPELLING,
NOW WE KNOW.
IT'S EFFICIENT.
>> IF YOU'RE GOG GET A DECK
BUILT ON YOUR HOUSE, AND FIVE
HASIDIC JEWS SHOW UP TO BUILD
IT.
YOU ARE GOING TO CALL JOSE.
>>
>> Larry: ARE POSITIVE
STEREOTYPES OKAY?
>> IT'S BETTER THAN A NEGATIVE
STEREOTYPE.
>> Larry: EXACTLY.
>> IT'S ON THE WAY TO BEING
BETTER.
>> I GUESS SOME PEOPLE FEEL
PIGEONHOLED BUT IT'S ALSO LIKE
DO YOU FIT THE STEREOTYPE?
WE'LL HIRE YOU, TO FINISH DECK
OR WHATEVER IT IS.
>> BUT, LARRY, YOU'RE BLACK.
YOU HAVE THE BIG [BLEEP]
STEREOTYPE.
I DON'T HAVE THAT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY GAVE US.
>> Larry: NO, BUT WE ALWAYS--
LOOK, LOOK--
>> I'M PUERTO RICAN, THEY SAY WE
STEAL. IT'S NOT THE SAME
>> Larry: WELL DON'T STEAL MY
BIG [BLEEP].
HOW ABOUT THAT?